[Música]
Bienvenidos a un episodio más de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro cordero Este primero de julio
cumplió 50 años la administración para
el control de drogas en Estados Unidos
conocida en América Latina como la DEA
por sus siglas en inglés este polémico
organismo fue creado en su origen para
combatir el tráfico y la fabricación de
sustancias ilícitas con el único
objetivo de eliminar el consumo de
drogas aplicando programas conjuntos en
los países donde se produce y transita
algo que ha tenido luces y sombras en
France 24 repasamos sus inicios como
organización algunas de sus polémicas Y
cómo fue su actuación contra algunos de
los principales carteles
latinoamericanos el organismo fue
concebido durante la administración del
expresidente Richard Nixon tan solo dos
años después de que este mandatario
declarara la guerra a las drogas por el
aumento de consumidores que Estados
Unidos estaba registrando estas
adicciones venían sobre todo de
veteranos de la guerra de Vietnam
quienes habían comenzado a consumir en
sus años en el frente con el beneplácito
del ejército así declaró Richard Nixon
la guerra a las drogas en junio de 1971
el enemigo Público número uno de Estados
Unidos es el consumo de drogas para
combatir y derrotar a este enemigo es
necesario librar una nueva ofensiva
total he pedido al congreso que
proporcione la autoridad legislativa y
los fondos para alimentar este tipo de
ofensiva
será una ofensiva mundial que abordará
problemas desde las fuentes de
suministro así como los estadounidenses
que pueden estar estacionados en el
extranjero donde quiera que estén en el
mundo
el objetivo de combatir el origen de la
droga puso sobre la mira a algunos
países latinoamericanos y la DEA se
convirtió en la punta de lanza del plan
estadounidense contra las drogas además
de controlar el narcotráfico en su
territorio Estados Unidos comenzó a
financiar la persecución de las
sustancias ilícitas en países como
México y Colombia y la DEA compartió
operativos junto a las fuerzas locales
con el objetivo de terminar con grandes
carteles como el de Medellín y Cali en
Colombia o el de Guadalajara en México
en Colombia la presencia de la DEA fue
notoria especialmente a partir de la
década de 1980 llegando a colaborar con
las autoridades locales para esos años
la cocaína era la droga que más
preocupaba a Estados Unidos y Colombia
su principal productora la lucha contra
el narcotráfico llevó a que A mediados
de la década de los 90 los carteles de
Medellín y Cali fueran desarticulados y
la DEA vendió como un éxito el asesinato
de capos de la droga como Pablo Escobar
y Gonzalo Rodríguez gacha Alias el
Mexicano o la detención y posterior
extradición de los hermanos Rodríguez
orejuela sin embargo tras la
desaparición de los carteles colombianos
otras organizaciones criminales
guerrillas y grupos narco-paramelitares
ocuparon su lugar en el mercado del
narcotráfico algo que posteriormente
traería consecuencias como el
recrudecimiento del conflicto armado
colombiano y controvertidas mega
inversiones militares de Estados Unidos
en el territorio como el plan Colombia
además la DEA protagonizó algunas
polémicas en suelo colombiano como la
supuesta colaboración con el grupo Los
pepes para dar caza a Pablo Escobar
desde el año
estas acusaciones vinieron por parte de
miembros de grupos paramilitares
colombianos que implicaron a la DEA a
asegurar que entrenaron y permitieron
que esta Alianza formada por
paramilitares como los hermanos castaño
por la cúpula del Cartel de Cali y por
enemigos de Pablo Escobar persiguiera e
intentara dar caza al líder del Cartel
de Medellín
polémicas que también se dieron en
México unos años antes en 1990 la DEA
coordinó El secuestro y traslado a
Estados Unidos del Doctor Mexicano
Humberto Álvarez machain por su supuesta
implicación en la tortura y posterior
asesinato de la gente Enrique kiki
Camarena en 1985 un miembro de la DEA
que consiguió infiltrarse en el cartel
de Guadalajara el problema es que esta
detención se dio sin conocimiento del
gobierno mexicano algo que creó una
crisis diplomática con Estados Unidos
que duraría más de 10 años además su
desempeño en México también tuvo luces y
Sombras aunque se consiguió junto con el
estado mexicano de tener a grandes
figuras como Miguel Ángel Félix Gallardo
o el Chapo Guzmán El poder de los
carteles se ha multiplicado en los
últimos 40 años y lo podemos ver en esta
gráfica en un inicio básicamente había
dos grandes carteles que era el de
Guadalajara y el clan del Golfo pero con
los años esos carteles se multiplicaron
y podemos ver que hubo varios como la
creación de varios como el de Sinaloa
Juárez Tijuana o La Familia Michoacana
además aunque el gobierno mexicano del
expresidente Felipe Calderón decidió a
partir de 2006 declarar la guerra a los
carteles con el apoyo económico y
militar de Estados Unidos sus resultados
han sido más que cuestionados se estima
que desde entonces más de 350.000
personas han sido asesinadas y 72.000
están desaparecidas según los datos
oficiales aunque las cifras podrían ser
mayores un costo altísimo que no ha
detenido el flujo del narcotráfico
por estas cuestiones se ha puesto en
entredicho el papel de la DEA y de
Estados Unidos y algunos críticos
afirman que la guerra contra las drogas
se ha perdido El ejemplo más claro es la
crisis sanitaria que vive actualmente
Estados Unidos con decenas de miles de
adictos a drogas tan dañinas como el
fentanilo el enfoque bélico no ha
conseguido frenar al narcotráfico y solo
ha causado violencia en Estados Unidos y
en América Latina especialmente entre
las poblaciones más desfavorecidas la
cuestión ahora es intentar Buscar otros
caminos que algunos defienden que están
en la legalización y control de drogas
por parte de los estados Aunque la
oposición a esto sigue siendo muy fuerte
con esto concluimos si quieren conocer
más historias sigan conectados a France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]